[Musique]
moi
non
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la comtesse des carpates
enfin je me trouvais dans cette région
d'inquiétantes réputation les hautes
tatras qui font partie des monts
carpates
j'avais décidé quelques camarades à
m'accompagner dans mon voyage sous le
prétexte d'aller skier sur ces pentes
sauvage
nous étions arrivés 10 février
je venais d'avoir 17 ans j'ignorais à
quels dangers j'allais devoir me mesurer
même j'étais courageux et curieux de
nature
et puis avant mon départ marie la fille
que j'aimais m'avait donné sa photo et
une paire de bottes fourrées sa photo
sur mon coeur et ses bottes aux pieds je
me sentais invincible
nous nous livrions donc aux joies du ski
quand soudain je me trouvais isolé de
mes camarades déconcerté je me mis à
descendre en slalom à travers une forêt
serre et de mélèzes
le crépuscule avaient envahi le ciel
enfin sur le versant opposé de faible
lueur trou r la neige des maisons jeu
débouchait sur une piste bordée de
congères qui menait bien à un village
j'étais fourbus avec soulagement
j'entendis derrière moi le tintement des
clochettes d'un traîneau mettant
retourné je distinguerai des lanternes
vertes qui oscillait à chaque cahot du
véhicule je me place est au centre de la
piste et me mis à jeter le bras le
traîneau ralenti l'été noir et or de
style romantique est tiré par des chiens
eskimos à l'arrière de mou sur une sorte
de coffre au blond fouet en main se
tenait un homme de stature gigantesque
au crâne rasé vêtu de cuir sont et puis
je m'aperçus l assise dans le traîneau
emmitouflées dans les fourrures blanc
joue seul son visage émerger un visage
d'une beauté irréelle
très pâle avec d'immenses yeux noirs
pathétique en se posant sûrement il sur
une expression intéressés et même charme
et j'attendais qu'elle me fasse signe de
montée à ses côtés au lieu de cela le
fouet et claqua et le traîneau s'éloigna
j'étais fou de rage en serrant les dents
j'ai parcouru les quelques kilomètres
qui me séparait encore du village sans
des chaussées mes skis car la neige en
contre et les ruelles
je me mis à la recherche d'une auberge
gens découvrent et une au fond d'une
cour sont l'homme qui va m'ouvrir me
conduisit à une table devant une
cheminée où brûlent être un bon feu en
dépit de son accueillant pressé je
remarquais son air soucieux
je lui demande s il avait aperçu mes
compagnons il me répondit que non qu'il
n'avait pas vue d'étrangers depuis fort
longtemps
personne ne s'aventure marché nous
rapport aux disparitions m'explique
at-il avec gêne en me servant d'une
soupe au chou et un verre d'alcool du
pays pour me réchauffer le sang en fait
un vrai en boyau homo disparition
j'avais bondi sur ma chaise c'était cela
le mystère que j'étais venu élucidés et
qu'elle disparition interrogeait d'un
air un différend sans façon l'homme sa
seat en face de moi est repris chez nous
une fois l'an un habitant disparaît on
ne le revoit plus jamais et ça n'arrive
pas seulement dans notre village non
dans tous ceux de la région c'est pareil
et vous n'avez trouvé aucune explication
à ces disparitions
aucune et le plus bizarre c'est que les
gens disparaissent toujours un 11
février les excités cette fois jamais
crier à 11 février mais aujourd'hui nous
sommes le 10 alors la nouvelle
disparition c'est pour demain et oui
pour demain ça fait trois disparus déjà
dans ma parenté
il y en a qui ont pensé à une bête
monstrueuse comme jadis en france dans
le gévaudan une bête objectif qui n'a
trait sur son calepin la date du 11
février pour accomplir son forfait il
soupira de l' angoisse au fond des yeux
il n'y a pas d'explication je vous dis
après ça vous n'avez plus vouloir dormir
sous mon toit
je me levais de table en mai tirant au
contraire j'allais vous prier de me
montrer ma chambre
la femme de l'aubergiste qui astiquer
des cuivres interrompu sa besogne à la
chercher une énorme clé si vous voulez
bien me suivre me dit-elle d'une voix
sourde dans l'escalier en colimaçon je
lui demandais c'est une coutume du pays
d'astiquer les cuivres à 10 heures du
soir
non me répondit-elle si je fais tout
reluire dans la maison ses rapports à la
visite de madame la comtesse
elle nous apporte des cadeaux une fois
l'an le 11 février
une bien brave dame est pas fier c'est
une étrangère elle ne sort guère qu'à
cette époque de l'année et hors glace
son majordome fait les courses un homme
pas causants j'interrogeais haletant
elle se déplace dans un traîneau noir et
or et c'est giorgos est un grand type au
crâne rasé c'est cela c'est bien cela
dit la femme vous les avez rencontré
donc c'est vrai qu'elle va bientôt
commencer ses visites
madame la comtesse me descend dans les
villages qu'une fois l'an le 11 février
les idiots ils n'avaient pas fait le
rapprochement entre les disparitions et
la visite annuelle de la comtesse sur
d'entrevoir la solution de l'énigme
je souhaitais le bonsoir airs fermer ma
porte
la chambre était propre
mais je remarquais avec contrariété une
toile d'araignée au plafond une toile
d'araignée occupé par sa propriétaire
j'ai horreur de ces bestioles ajouté une
de mes bottes que j'avais enfilé après
avoir quitté mes chaussures de ski et
l'a lancée en direction de la toile
touché satisfait je me couchais et
fermer les yeux
mais je ne pu trouver le sommeil
exaspérée de me retourner sans cesse sur
mon mac là j'ai décidé d'aller faire un
tour au dehors
l'aubergiste me criait de sa chambre ne
vous attardez pas jeune homme par ce
froid les oiseaux tombent des arbres
tout gelé dur comme des pierres l'air
était glacée rivet mais mon sens
cognette à mes tempes
je me penchais pour ramasser une poignée
de neige et mon faute et le visage
brusquement ce fut le trou noir je cru
tomber dans un abîme sans fond
ce malaise ne durera pas le contact de
la neige me ranima et en relevant la
tête j'ai eu la surprise d'une vision
extraordinaire se détachant sous la
pleine lune un fabuleux château se
dressait au dessus de moi
il semblait écrasé la vallée avec ses
murailles les normes il poussait ses
tours et le hardi vers le ciel certaines
d'entre elles se perdait dans les nuages
château de la comtesse murmurait ge
comme on ne les juge pas remarqué en
arrivant c'est là que se cache le secret
des eaux tatras mais le froid était si
terrible que j'ai entrepris de regagner
l'auberge tandis que sonnaient les douze
coups de minuit je fus surpris de
trouver les maisons illuminées un peu
partout des clameur s'élevait bienvenue
à madame la comtesse longue vie à madame
la comtesse le très noir et or était
immobilisé sur la place du village
la comtesse souriante tendait à chacun
une main diaphane aux doigts longs et
souples
giorgos descendu de son piédestal
distribué des colis enrubanné avec un
air farouche
nous n'attendions pas votre visite à
cette heure tardive madame la comtesse
dit un homme en se courbant dames et
obséquieux
elle répondit d'une voix douce ou
chantaient un léger accent ce que cette
année je commence mes visites par votre
village est soudainement aperçu vous
êtes étrangères la région n'est ce pas
me dit-elle d'un ton charmeur en effet
je m'appelle michael et j'aimerais
visiter votre château est ce possible
avec plaisir monte donc à côté de moi je
m'assurer que la photo de marie était
toujours dans la poche gauche de mon
anorak et j'obéis les villageois c'est
carter et le traîneau fils à bientôt sur
la piste gelée mauchiens mène un train
d'enfer fige remarquer machinalement mes
yeux se posait sur les bêtes et je
sursaute et comment avais-je pu les
prendre pour des chiens ski mots c'est
oryza serrer ses yeux oblique s'échine
maigre c'était des loups le traîneau de
la comtesse été tirée par une bande de
loups la gorge sèche je me recroqueville
s ou les fourrures la comtesse et
giorgos disputait avec véhémence
ils parlaient tous deux le grec que
j'avais étudié en classe le grec ancien
ce qui était surprenant
vous avez pris des risques u17 il en
invitant ce galopin au vu et au su de
tout le village
vous êtes une impétueuse une entité cela
ne vous a pas réussi dans le passé
qui oserait me soupçonner mois lui
répliqua tel ce jeune homme assurant
meilleur goût que les paysans je veux
lui faire visiter mes ateliers de
tissage tout de suite et notre tournée
vous savez bien que vous n'avez droit
qu'à 24 heures tout de suite ordonna la
comtesse vite au chaton giorgos je me
sens faible j'ai besoin de prendre et
consommer à nouveau à mon attention ce
sourire enjôleur si suave
savez-vous une car elle me dit elle que
je file la soie que je fais de la
tapisserie
vous pourrez admirer tout cela avant
avant que vous nous qui pied n'ont été
des plus sages quand mayer gosse à
l'arrière du traîneau de le cueillir
hors du village et de l'enfermer comme
les autres dans le coffre que j'ai sous
les pieds je vous préviens que je
comprends le grec lançait jamais crash
de la sueur au front en dépit du froid
dément cela n'a plus aucune importance
à présent elle avait répondu d'un ton
triomphant son ra langue il avait quitté
j'avais m'écouter un être dur déterminer
de quel prix devrais-je payer ma
curiosité la main de la comtesse cherche
à la mienne remonta jusqu'à mon poignet
l'an cirque la gt sont prisonniers
le traîneau s'engouffrant entrons dans
une ouverture du rocher sur lequel était
bâti le château nous débouche âme dans
un parc immense que la lune éclairait
comme en plein jour
giorgos d'éclat les loups et les lâches
encadrés par mais de jolis et je visite
et d'immenses atelier de tissage
aménagés dans les souterrains des
torches allumées faisait jouer les
couleurs somptueuses des soieries mais
je regardais ailleurs pour tenter de
voir ce qu'on ne montraient pas tandis
que giorgos et des la comtesse a déroulé
une tapisserie je bondis et enfiler un
couloirs tortueux à son extrémité
partaient un escalier dont je gravi les
marches quatre à quatre
giorgos sur mes talons la poursuite du
rally en selle obscur vide immense comme
des cathédrales à nouveau des escaliers
des corridors je parvins dans les
combles pousser une porte et marc était
médusé des centaines de mannequins au
visage décolorés étaient alignés l'a
suspendu à des cintres des mannequins de
taille humaine costumés en paysans et
paysannes il semblait fabriqué dans une
matière si légère que le courant des
rentrées avec moi les faisait se
balancer tournoyer dans le clair de lune
à quoi servait tous ses mannequins au
lieu de s'éclaircir
le mystère s'épaissit c'est giorgos
n'eut aucune peine à me récupérer nous
rejoignons la comtesse qui me jetant un
regard moqueur
puis je vous rappeler conteste qu'il
serait temps de songer à votre consommer
lui dit giorgos le consommer c'est vous
ajouta-t-il sans ironie en me fixant
dans les yeux
puis il m'entraîne à de force à la suite
de la comtesse qui gagnait le parc n'a
pas vif les yeux des loups luizet dans
les fourrés
leur présence rendait inutile toute
tentative de fuite
nous étions parvenus à une clairière
bordée de sombres sapin vous n'avez
guère apprécié mes oeuvres mika elle me
dit la comtesse d'une voix sèche
peut-être préférerez-vous celle là entre
deux branches l'étendue des paies fil de
soie de façon à former un dessin
géométrique très pur
tous ces fils de soie étaient recouverts
de givre et étincelait comme des
rivières de diamants c'était féerique
on dirait une toile abstraite murmurait
ge
selmon juste michael reagan à la
comtesse admirer la symétrie parfaite
des motifs de cette toile il n'y manque
que le personnage central objectait d'un
air faussement dégagé avec un personnage
central ce ne serait plus une oeuvre
abstraite
encore une fois vous avez raison entrons
dans le réalisme le plus concret
lentement elle s'avança vers son oeuvre
elle portait avec grâce une combinaison
une seule pièce noire et brillante
arrivé au pied de ce fil est
resplendissant elle s'immobilise à comme
pour se concentrer puis elle se mit à y
grimper avec agilité le signifie ce
numéro d'équilibriste persiflage tout à
fait dérouter giorgos sitavir atroce tu
n'as pas encore compris regarde de tous
tes yeux après ce sera trop tard nous
n'est pas autorisé à me tutoyer vous le
majordome hurlait ge pour crâner la
comtesse s'était immobilisé au centre de
son fils est vertical
son visage d'ordinaire si palm paru
insensiblement s'assombrir comme un
négatif de photographier puis ses bras
ses jambes se dédouble airs tandis que
son corps se ratatine est en boule
elle avait à présent huit membres l'ont
aiguerelles qu'elle se mette à agiter
dans un mouvement lancinant son visage
avait fait place à une sorte de masque
de momies velud aux contours incertains
et dans cette tête noire et immonde des
lèvres de femmes se dit cerner encore
cherché à exprimer les paroles confuse
j'avais sous les yeux une araignée
géante au centre de sa toile et tenant
cette métamorphose n'est ce pas
chetaille hausse à mon oreille vois-tu
michael si les dieux grecs sont morts
leur malédiction leur survivent cette
jeune femme vivait jadis en libye un
pays de la mer egée c'était une virtuose
dans l'art du tissage la déesse athéna
en prix tombent rage
la jeune femme se moque adèle résultat
la tisserande fut transformée en
araignée pour l'éternité mois giorgos
j'ai été chargé de la surveiller ce pays
lui a plu elle ya installé son repère là
où dans sa toile les pattes parcouru de
soubresauts elle m'observait brusquement
d'une poussée giorgos me précipita vers
la toile les doigts de ma main gauche
rencontrèrent une matière dont le
contact me fait horreur
ils restèrent coller à ses fils lui en
ai glace et je tentais de me dégager par
de brusques traction ans marc boutin
dans la neige puis en ajoutant de façon
incohérente
mais plus je me débattais plus aggraver
mon cas
bientôt toute ma main fut prise puis mon
poignet puis mon bras alors je renonçais
voilà repris giorgos elle va pouvoir
descendre vers toi elle va te frôler
avec cp 10 palpe ce ne sera pas
désagréable il y aura bien un petit
moment difficile quand elle va te perds
c'est avec ces quelques scènes venimeuse
pour tous mobilisés mais tu verras
l'effet est foudroyant ensuite tu ne
sentira plus rien des frissons ce coin
est ma colonne vertébrale mes cheveux se
dresser sur ma tête elle commençait à
descendre j'apercevais sa bouche
l'élève qu'on avait disparu ce n'était
plus qu un orifice hideuse qui se
tendaient goulûment vers moi avec un
bruit des cayes
après continue ailleurs gosse
imperturbable elle va aspirer
l'intérieur de ton corps c'est ainsi que
font les araignées avec les mouches pas
sur toi elle laissera ton enveloppe
externe intacte
reconnaissable nous les conservons
toutes en souvenir pendus à des cintres
dans les combles tu les as vu tout à
l'heure
ta place tu y as tant elle était très
proche à présent moins les yeux hagards
je revoyais ma vie à toute vitesse le
visage de mes parents
celui de mary mary mentalisme
je repensais brusquement à la minuscule
toile d'araignée au plafond de la
chambre rapidement jeté ma botte droite
puis je l'a projeté sur le monstre avec
la force décuplée que seuls peuvent
donner le désespoir et l'épouvanté la
toile entière vibre à comme une voile de
navires dans la tempête et se déchira en
lambeaux prenez garde a rappelé cria
giorgos trop tard une des pattes de
l'abominable ben est retombé dans le
vide inerte disloqué quant à moi sous le
choc je me retrouvais libre des voix
parvenait jusqu'à moi de loin
de très loin j'ouvris les yeux j'étais
dans la salle de l'auberge
je compris que j'étais sauvée mais
l'horreur persistait en moi c'est elle
la comtesse la cause des disparitions
murmurait ch
il a le délire dit la femme de
l'aubergiste notre comtesse si
charitable
je me réjouis temps de la voir demain je
demandais février mans demain mais quel
jour sommes nous dont est toujours le 10
février jeune homme me répondit
l'aubergiste votre évanouissement n'a
pas duré cinq minutes
de la fenêtre de ma chambre je vous ai
vu tomber alors j'ai alerté mes voisins
et voilà on vous a ramené ici une
horloge quelque part saône à 11 coups
nous étions le 10 février et la comtesse
n'avait pas encore fait sa visite
annuelle ce que je venais de vivre
n'était donc un horrible cauchemar dû
sans doute à l'alcool de l'aubergiste
une immense joie mme envahi étant dit
qu'on m'aiderait à me mettre au lit je
juré de ne plus boire de ma vie
le lendemain matin j'ai décidé de
quitter le pays je ne pouvais plus
supporter cette neige c'est sombre forêt
j'avais envie de retrouver marie de rire
avec elle du cauchemar qui ne cessait de
me hanter je fis mes adieux aubergiste
et chausser mes skis
on avait expliqué que la piste par
laquelle j'étais arrivé croisait une
route qui menait à la ville avant de
m'éloigner jeu lever les yeux par deux
châteaux bien sûr d'ailleurs même s'il y
en avait eu 1
je n'aurais pas pu l'apercevoir car de
gros nuage s'étirait aura de la vallée
au bout de trois kilomètres soudain
j'entendis de tintement des clochettes
d'un traîneau qui arrivaient vers moi
dechatte
bien sûr d'ailleurs même s'il y en avait
eu 1 je n'aurais pas pu l'apercevoir car
de gros nuage s'étirait aura de la
vallée au bout de trois kilomètres
soudain j'entends dit le tintement des
clochettes d'un traîneau qui arrivaient
vers moi je gagnais le bord de la piste
pour le laisser passer
c'était un traîneau noir et or
tiré par des chiens eskimos debout à
l'arrière se donnait giorgos et à
l'intérieur entouré de paquets rubané la
comtesse en arrivant à ma hauteur le
traîneau ralenti la comtesse très pâle
se souleva admis et j'aperçus son bras
droit plâtré jusqu'à l'épaule nous
regards se croisèrent je lui dans le
sien impossible de s'y tromper
elle le savait que je savais à bientôt
arachne murmurait ge
le traîneau l'emporta j'avais renoncé à
comprendre ce qui mettait réellement
arrivé mais j'étais décidé à revenir
plus tard dans les monts carpates pour
démasquer la comtesse et aussi pour la
revoir